dealing with free riders avoiding them
and cutting them off says brian all
right we got a freeloader question all
right what do you got for me bro you got
free loaders in your life
you're muted
there we go uh not anymore i'm i'm
pretty successful at uh
cutting off dead growth okay now in my
life actually i'd like to say a special
thanks to you i came across your content
right after i was going through divorce
uh came out of the hospital for uh
having cancer removed and that's when
you know she uh she lost her [ __ ] and oh
excuse my language she lost it and i was
in madrid spain i had to call the cops
to get out of the house it was amazing
she left you when you had cancer oh yeah
no i got out of the hospital the day i
got out of the hospital having having it
removed from the base of my skull
uh she started like i mean she was gonna
try to mess me up physically you know i
had net collar on all this stuff and
it was a bad deal man and you talk about
how how you can get uh run through the
ringer on a divorce try doing that stuff
in madrid spain man and
those liberal countries like that was
she spanish lady like she was domestic
or did you bring her from the states
no no no no i met her when i was in the
military in spain oh okay all right so
yeah so you're past that now
yeah that's that crazy crazy latin
woman's gone okay yeah
special special thanks to you on that
you know i've used your content and got
your book and all that stuff has been
very useful to me um and this is a
question i've kind of hashed it out and
answered it myself
uh the answer is really kind of simple
is
yeah
if you surround yourself with people
that are at your level or better then
you're probably not gonna have to worry
about them trying to freeload off of you
but generally i'm a pretty generous
person i do pretty well for myself i've
got a good job
and i don't mind spreading my money
around you know
but uh i've had i've had uh issues with
with people taking that generously
generosity as weakness
and then you know you got to cut
somebody into your life and that's not
necessarily fun either if are they
having a hard time saying goodbye to
people or
not so much i just uh wonder if there
might be a better way to do it than
ghost not inviting them in your life to
begin with
yeah i agree with that right i mean
you know
there's an old saying that like um
when's the best time to fire somebody
when it comes to
an employer can you know considering the
idea of getting rid of a problem
employing the company the answer to the
question is
the very moment that you realize that
they're a problem
the thing being though is that human
beings are way too forgiving it's like
i'll give them another chance i'll try
to change you know trade change them or
you know improve their lives or coach
them or whatever and it's like
at some point as a guy you get to the
point where it's like i'm not gonna play
captain seva insert whatever it's not
just captain savajo it's like captain
save the employee or captain save this
dude or the friend of mine from high
school or whatever it happens to be like
just don't invite them in your life to
begin with if you know their problem
it's hard to do
right but you're going to leave people
behind as you do and you have to be okay
with that right i've i've walked away
from groups people
my entire life i do it all the [ __ ]
time
right i mean if you've watched my
channel for the last seven or eight
years you've seen me do it at least once
right
you have to be okay with walking away
from [ __ ]
yeah and that's kind of the uh the
conclusion that i'd come to myself on
this but i figured you know it'd be a
good a good question to roll in with and
maybe spread that uh that knowledge
among others here too yeah i mean as
soon as you figure out that you're the
smartest guy in the room get the hell
out of the room i agree okay all right i
appreciate it hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you